murders that will live on in infamy a
twisted love story that actually
happened and an entire alternate
screenplay here's what the ending of
killers of the flower moon really means
killers of the flower Moon opens with
the oage people in Oklahoma striking oil
by the 1920s the discovery had turned
them into the wealthiest group of people
in the world except that racist laws
require white Guardians to handle their
wealth many oage are being murdered and
the police are doing nothing to solve
the cases William King there one white
man using this situation for his own
benefit and ropes his War veteran nephew
Ernest buckheart into an elaborate
criminal scheme marry into an oage
family then kill the members off one by
one until the oil money is all theirs
Ernest actually falls in love with his
new wife Molly but still partakes in the
violence against her family due to a
combination of greed and his uncle's
manipulation I do love that money
sir Molly is diabetic and gets
prescribed the new rare and extreme
extremely expensive synthetic insulin
distrusting the doctors she has her
husband perform the shots for her
unbeknownst to her Ernest is following
the doctor's orders to mix the insulin
with the poison to slow her down
gradually sickening her afraid she's
going to die Molly uses what little
strength she has left to travel to
Washington DC to plead to President
Calvin cage for an investigation into
the unsolved murders it works Agents
from the Bureau of Investigation led by
Tom white come in and arrest Ernest hey
casually turns himself in confident
he'll be ruled innocent in the Final Act
of killers of the flower Moon Ernest
waivers back and forth on whether to
testify against hail Ernest makes
confessions only to take them back and
claim he was forced to by the Boi he
shows up in court without realizing he
and his uncle have the same lawyer WS
Hamilton who works further to scare him
off from testifying in jail Ernest
learns his youngest daughter has died of
whooping cough but surprisingly Molly is
still alive and has gotten help
recovering from the poisoning Ernest has
an emotional reunion with his wife the
trials continue to unearth evidence of
the conspiracy despite Tail's best
efforts to suppress it and Ernest
ultimately testifies and pleads guilty
to killing rer and Bill Smith by blowing
up their house but he won't confess to
everything in his last scene he lies to
Molly still saying the shots he gave her
were just regular insulin the film
continues into an epilogue of sorts
where the story of the oage murders is
presented via a live performance of a
True Crime radio play the energetic
fast-paced deliveries and wacky sound
effects make it easy to miss all the
details but this epilog describes what
happened in the aftermath of the story
we hear how Ernest and hail both ended
up free on parole despite their life
sentences and in a cameo from director
Martin scorsi himself how Molly's
obituary made no mention of the murders
the final shot of the film shows a
massive oage drum and dancing circle
from overhead like SC say's past crime
film killers of the flower moon is about
the all consuming power of greed in the
American capitalist system here this
theme also plays into the Reckoning with
the mass genocide of indigenous people
Ernest makes for a particularly
complicated protagonist because on the
one hand he seems to genuinely love his
wife but on the other he's both so
greedy and so easily manipulated that
this love ultimately means nothing more
than anything nnest is a weak man and
the way he's pulled back and forth over
the course of the trial in the film's
final AC serves to emphasize that
weakness I just love
money I love it as much as I love my
wife the scene in which Hamilton brings
Ernest to a meeting with the oil company
execs to put the fear of God into him
evokes no BT scene in network another
film about the forces of the market
doing everything to suppress descent you
might watch the Final Act of killers of
the flower Moon hoping for Earnest to
finer strength to stand up to hail and
acknowledge his crimes but his
confession offers little cathar
ernest's final interactions with Molly
only served to emphasize his dishonesty
and cowardice Molly never really trusted
him identifying him as a coyote from the
beginning but nonetheless chose to spend
her life with him by the end of the film
she fully sees through his Charming
facade wanting nothing more to do with
him on the most basic level presenting
the final facts of the story in the form
of a live radio show offers a more
entertaining alternative to the standard
practice of closing historical films
with information or title card the
choice to present this information so
entertainingly however comes with its
own layers of commentary on the nature
of the True Crime genre as a whole and
uncore says he own responsibilities with
killers of the flower moon in particular
for one thing there's the question of
entertainment as a distraction after
over 3 hours of methodically paced
storytelling suddenly getting bombarded
with a presentation so fast and so silly
makes it harder to take in the sadness
of the story being told this radio show
is specifically stated to be associate
iated with FBI director Jay Edgar Hoover
which raises questions about the
propagandistic use of such Stories the
images of the theater audience recall
how scorsi ended the Wolf of Wall Street
forcing the viewer to reflect on their
own attraction to such stories in the
first place not letting himself off the
hook either Score says he appears on
stage as part of the radio show but when
he's talking about Molly's divorce
remarriage and death the bells and
whistles fade away he wants us to take
this in that's what killers of the
flower moon is trying to accomplish to
offer serious reflection on tragedy
within the apparatus of mass
entertainment whereas Ernest is a sort
of villain who lacks any serious sense
of right or wrong hail is the kindest
convinced himself he's in the right
which is what makes him so scary he's
convinced the oage nation he's their
Ally and he can talk at length about the
virtues of their culture yet he still
wants to take everything from them
because he views their fall as a
historic inevitability oh Sage they're
going to go their time is over it's an
even more extreme parallel to Ernest
professing love for the same woman he's
slowly poisoning speaking to Ernest in
jail hail delivers a chilling monologue
affirming his confidence that history
will vindicate him because all the anger
people hold towards him now will end up
forgotten to some degree this confidence
was scarily well founded he and the
other convicted killers were eventually
let free while other Killers weren't
caught or convicted at all and the
broader culture genuinely forgot about
the story for a long time yet even if
White America forgot the oage nation did
not forget when hail was let out of
prison his release was met with protest
and though it's taken far too long the
existence of killers of the flower Moon
as both a book and a movie it's also a
rejoinder to hail's view of History what
might have once been forgotten is now
being remembered on a large scale as
with the radio epilog the closing shot
of killers of the flower moon seems to
serve two primary purposes one stylistic
and one thematic the stylistic purpose
of the final shot is to sheer visual
Splendor of it at all with a reported
budget of $200 million this production
had plenty of resources for stunning
scenes with massive crowds and fancy
camera work but Score says he restrains
those more grandiose instincts from much
of the film in favor of a more intimate
focus on character drama the ending
offers a place where such a spectacle
fits comfortably thematically the final
shot returns a central focus of the film
to the oage people trying to navigate
the issue of perspective was one of the
challenges of making the film most of
the iant Native American characters are
killed Midway through the film and Molly
the main exception to this Rule and one
of the most important characters still
has to spend a large chunk of the film
bedridden while the white male
exploiters take center stage in the
drama presenting the oage perspective on
this tragedy however was one of scor's
priorities in telling this story the
movie opens from their perspective and
after the radio drama segment entirely
about white America's Viewpoint the
closing shot Returns the movie to them
the start to the credit solidifies this
with the film's title displayed in the
oage language before it is shown in
English scor's thoughtful Direction
continues even beyond the end of The
Narrative into the credits themselves
pay attention to the Sounds in the
background they're the sounds of nature
that mody teachers Earnest to listen to
at the start of their courtship when
Sight and Sound pointed this out in an
interview with scori he responded the
music comes from there it always did
that's how music originated from
imitating animals and the sounds of
insects and so you get the goat singers
you get the ancient world the tragedy
again from that and that's for us to go
back to and to find comfort in I think
well before the release of killers of
the flower Moon oage Nation principal
Chief Joffrey Standing Bear who had
Score says he on the film's cultural
depictions discussed the filming of the
film's closing shot he revealed that it
was a relatively late edition telling
Tulsa well that I heard that Mr scori
and the producers are going to come back
and try to get a better ending by
showing everyone who was an extra in a
social dance where everyone's having a
good time speaking to Vogue during the
movie's premiere at the can film
festival Gladstone made sure to inform
people of one of her favorite details in
the true story that wasn't included in
the film it's not in this film but it's
important to me that people know that
Molly when she divorced Ernest she
didn't just cut and run she went back
and got the money from him that had
embezzled from her in an interview
magazine talk with director Kelly
reichart bladstone described using
quotes from those a court cases to base
a performance of the film's ending
scenes on saying I don't want harm to
perform my husband but I want the truth
to come out for what it is closer to
release SC said he had talked more about
aspects of the film's final acts in
interviews he told the New Yorker that
the film's ending was harder to right
than the beginning explaining the first
two hours we were moving along the
second two hours boy is is getting a
little long in the tooth as they say the
killers of the flower Moon movie
captures much of the book's content but
it's completely different in in terms of
structure the book is divided into three
major sections or Chronicles the first
Chronicle The Marked woman is centered
around Molly and her account of the
crimes against her family the second the
evidence man follows Tom White and the
Boi as they uncover hail's big
conspiracy finally the reporter shifts
the focus of the book's author David
Grant as he personally investigates the
case further and uncovers the extent to
which the Boi overall failed to bring
about Justice when this money started
coming
we should have known it came with
something else because it's a white
man's money even if Score says his film
adaptation has stuck closer to the
structure of the book there was almost
no way the book sending could be
directly adapted to even attempt that
the film would either have to shift to a
documentary format or there would need
to be a big meta framing device involved
scull says he gets a bit mess up with
the radio show epilog but that's
different from making the whole third
act about a writer living nearly a
century later as far as we know killers
of the flower Moon didn't have an
alternate ending filmed there is however
an entire alternate screenplay Eric
Ross's original draft was closer to the
mystery structure of the book as well as
to more traditional Western with Tom
white as a primary Viewpoint character
as Roth and scor sayi worked on
developing the script they realized they
had to completely start over for
multiple reasons putting the focus on
the Boi made it too much of a white
savior story and with hail so obviously
a villain with Robert dairo in the role
the Boi Centric version f as a
compelling mystery DiCaprio who was
originally going to play White
reportedly questioned scori where's the
heart in this movie scor said he
determined that the heart was in the
Twisted romance between Ernest and Molly
a topic which only became more
interesting to him while doing research
and speaking with members of the O age
who claimed the love between the couple
was real despite how badly Ernest was
hurting Molly the CIO switched roles
from white to Earnest and the movie that
exists today came into being
[Music]
he